one last question,
last question only,
they would like,
that more peopleMigrationshintergrund for the AfD
get excited?
get involved in the AfD,
Muslims,
Africans,
anything.
why not?
when they share the values,
the free democratic basic order,
of course,
if they make n positive contribution and the
and that's what they do then,
then everything is perfectly fine.
who is talking about backgrounds and somehow skin color?
I never understood that anyway.
well, so when
their party friends like to talk about Negroes again and again,
is that for them n word that is problematic?
or yes,
that's a problematic word.
i don't like it either.
and there are also regulatory measures against this here
within the party.
that is not tolerated either.
something like that.
thank you for your time,
very much.
thank you for coming,
thank you very much
and have spun me here by the wolf.
thank you.